and you saw this with the Toronto Blue
Jays you saw this with Anthony bass who
came out and he he made a post that was
critical of Pride he felt the weight of
the liberal establishment on him and I'm
sorry to say he just came out and
apologized I made a post that was
hurtful to the private Community which
includes friends of mine and close
family members of my pride community and
I'm truly sorry for that pathetic what
the hell is the pride Community when did
we start using that phrase The Pride
Community we're not even referring now
to guys who are a little light in the
loafers or lesbians or anything no it's
the pride community